una nueva tragedia en gersón desde el
inicio de la invasión esta localidad ha
sido una de las más afectadas los
residentes no saben qué más esperar
después de la ocupación los constantes
bombardeos rusos Y por último la
voladura del dique de la presa de novaca
dicen que un amor mata a lo anterior Tal
vez sea lo mismo con la tragedia
una nueva tragedia silencia la anterior
ya que no se puede silenciar del todo
uno solo puede callarla un poquito Irina
quien es subdirectora de una escuela
local sufre también por los
contratiempos que las inundaciones
generan a sus alumnos
están muy limitados en sus movimientos
luego está la cuestión
psicológicamente diferentes se han
vuelto más adultos es difícil para mí
imaginarme diciéndoles que se comporten
de cierta manera que no rompan las
reglas toda la población del área se vio
afectada por la inundación
médico jefe de un hospital Recuerda la
primera noche tras la voladura de novaka
hofka
El primer día ingresamos a 136 personas
22 de las cuales tenían problemas de
movilidad la mayoría encía de ruedas
todos estaban en estado de estrés la
mayoría llegó con la ropa mojada y nada
más el sector agrícola clave en tiempos
de escasez perdió toda la cosecha del
año habíamos sembrado papa remolacha
zanahoria cebolla ajo calabacín como
somos agricultores sembramos todo con un
año de anticipación para poder comer más
tarde ahora no hay nada
estratégica para ambos contendientes La
Represa abastece de agua la anexada
Península de crimea mientras que su
destrucción ralentizó la contra ofensivo
ucraniana en esa zona una acusación
formulada por kiev